The Greeks and Romans gave us so much
that it's little wonder we
continue to sing their praises
as great inventors,
artists and writers.
But not everything they thought
has stood the test of time.
Here are five of their most absurd
pieces of wisdom.
Number one...
"If a woman says no she means yes."
- Ovid
A highly damaging piece of advice
from the Latin poet Ovid's
Guide to Love.
"Women act coy," he maintained
"and may even put up a fight,
but secretly they want
to be overcome in battle."
Now to women today, especially in the
era of #MeToo, it's pretty abhorrent.
In fact, the poem from which
this piece of advice comes
actually helped
to land Ovid in exile
for being so sexually explicit.
Two...
Dark skinned men produce black semen.
- Herodotus
Herodotus - the so called father of
history - believed this to be true,
both of Ethiopians
and certain Indians.
To modern eyes it may look racist.
But to him it was little more
than a curiosity worthy of note.
He did not provide a source
for this nugget,
apparently believing it to be true
simply on logical grounds.
Perhaps he thought it was one of
those "Well I never" anecdotes
that would enliven his histories
of Greece's wars against Persia.
Three...
Aristotle.
Together with Plato,
Aristotle was the most influential
philosopher from antiquity.
He wrote on everything,
from drama to animals.
But he did entertain some rather
peculiar ideas about biology.
He saw men and women
as completely different.
Men were hot and dry.
Women were cold and wet.
If reproduction happens properly,
he thought,
then the embryo should be male,
like its father.
A daughter is the result
of a man's semen being too weak
to overpower a woman's
reproductive matter.
Four...
"Women who see monkeys
during intercourse,
bear children who resemble
monkeys." -Soranus.
A medical marvel from Soranus -
a doctor of the Roman Empire.
His thinking is that you can inherit
not just the physical characteristics
of your parents,
but even the thoughts they had when
they were actually conceiving you.
Soranus thought it
particularly important
that a woman be sober during sex
just in case she conceived
a deranged child.
He also advised her against picturing
monkeys or other animals
in case the child
came out looking like one.
Far better to picture a statue
so that the child
might have long graceful limbs,
but hopefully not be too rigid
and cold.
Five...
"Beware the fifth day of the month,
it is dreadful"
- Hesiod
In the 7th Century BC,
a poet called Hesiod composed
a poem on the farmer's year.
He believed that some
days of the month
were more suitable for some
tasks than others,
and endeavoured to give land owners
the best possible advice.
Fifth days struck him
as peculiarly threatening.
Hesiod's misgivings
haven't stood the test of time.
But perhaps in the future
people will look back on us and laugh
for us finding
Friday the 13th so unlucky.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe
and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!